i would like to welcome those who have
just joined the session
we will be starting with today's session
in more five minutes thank you for
joining
and in the meanwhile we begin with the
session you can introduce yourself in
the chat box
and tell us about your educational or
research background and also your
research interest
thank you we are looking forward to hear
from you
hello everyone i would like to welcome
you all for the very first session of
bioinformatics for precision medicine
program
this program is designed to introduce
students and researchers to the field of
bioinformatics applications in precision
medicine
in this program we will explore how the
various omics data types generated in
these studies can be analyzed and
integrated to study the basic biology
associated with viruses and their hosts
cancer onset and development and
outcomes this online program will
include weekly sessions with an
instructor online tracking and review of
students progress access to all
resources and materials online for
self-paced learning access to export
guidance and problem solving education
and research pipelines and domain data
analysis on our big data server
in this session we will discuss about
overview of precision medicine program
current applications of bioinformatics
and precision medicine and much more
so to begin with what is precision
medicine
precision medicine is an emerging
approach for disease treatment and
prevention that takes into account
individual variability in genes
environment and lifestyle for each
person
this approach will allow doctors and
researchers to predict more accurately
which treatment and prevention strategy
for a particular disease will work in
which group of people
it is in contrast to a one-size-fits-all
approach in which disease treatment and
prevention strategies are developed for
the average person with less
consideration for the differences
between individuals
after decades of research we are poised
to enter a new era of medical practice
where detailed genetic and other
molecular information about the
patient's cancer is routinely used to
deploy effective patient-specific
remedies to treat it
we are about to enter the era of
precision medicine where biology is now
seen as a field of data science
biology is rapidly acquiring the
characters of data science
billions of data on genes proteins and
other molecules are compiled in large
files and systematically studied
analyzing this data will lead to more
knowledge and understanding about living
organisms including human health
biotechnology crops and livestock
this program will give an overview of
bioinformatics for students biologists
and clinicians
the influx of data associated
methodologies and data-driven research
makes bioinformatics for life sciences
as prominent as the emergence of
computers for the tech industry
the goal of the omixlogic programs is to
provide training in bioinformatics
enabling independent research guided by
mentors and pure example
developing a growing community with
shared passion for data-driven research
and appreciation of citizen science
enabling students clinicians and faculty
of all backgrounds to develop novel and
independent research using latest
technology in life science and data
science
the omixlogic portal gives students
options for analyzing a given data set
code dependent paths or code independent
paths these data sets and associated
publications can be used in several ways
you can learn bioinformatics without any
coding at all
for that in each project may explain the
analysis pipelines on the user-friendly
t-bioinfo platform for big data analysis
you can also learn the scripts behind
many of the steps learning to wrangle
clean visualize and analyze data in
popular languages like r and python in
order to create your own analysis
finally you can hear about the projects
and their research applications in our
mental guided programs where experts
share their experience and support
research projects developed by you
after using the t bioinfo platform to
visualize the pipelines and practice
analyzing students are then able to take
their theoretical knowledge to remember
and understand levels of blooms and
apply that in a project
they apply analyze and evaluate level of
claims
then check their comprehension with
levels and badges certification of
completion and test
similarly faculty should be able to
assign the omixlogic portal to their
students with the understanding that it
will give them holistic and
comprehensive knowledge of
bioinformatics beginning with bytes and
molecules and onto designing their own
question-based project
after completing this course you will
know how to do the following
read and understand bioinformatics
literature perform basic ngs data
analysis processing steps
analyze data and form hypothesis
prepare data for machine learning
crosstalk signals with gene databases
know what type of data is required to
answer scientific questions
create your own bioinformatics analysis
present your results in an organized way
all these skills are essential in
bioinformatics and some can be
translated to other fields
so let's start up by signing up on the
learn.comics logic portal this
educational portal will help you get
started on your bioinformatics journey
thank you just keep putting the link in
the chat box if you have not yet signed
up on the omixlogic portal you can take
this time to create an account for
yourself our team is here if you face
any of the technical issues so we'll be
here to assist you with that
you can either create an account for
yourself by putting in the details that
that are required or simply sign in by
using any one of your social media
accounts that would include a google
account facebook or your apple id or
orchid or twitter
thank you dr fatima
those who have already signed up can
maybe let us know in the chat box by
sending in a one or yes and others can
take this time to create an account for
themselves
meanwhile i'll go ahead so those who
have created their accounts already are
requested to complete their profile
a completed profile will have a profile
picture a full name with appropriate
capitalization
you should add the links to your social
media handles and also add a brief bio
about yourself that will consist of
educational background and research and
trust
the mentors can view your progress under
the activity tab the courses you are
currently completing will appear under
the courses tab and finally after the
completion of your course the
certificates will appear under the
certificates tab
so for different parts of the session we
will leverage or mix logic resources
that you can use to learn about
precision medicine
asynchronous coursework with theoretical
material quizzes and practical
assignments a cloud-based analytical
server where you can analyze large
genomic data and visualize results the
omixologic code playground where you can
practice coding in r and python as well
as a repository of project examples
and these methods will include hands-on
exercises on the tbi info platform which
provides a simple and intuitive user
interface for processing and
analysis and machine learning methods
for multi-omics data
throughout the course the users will be
given the directions to access the tbio
info platform for processing and
analysis of rna-seq data
the platform includes demo pipelines as
well as data management and analysis
cloud infrastructure to run
bioinformatics pipelines
different stages of analysis are
performed in different sections of this
multi-omics platform
and behind many of these methods are
scripts which are written in popular
coding languages such as art and python
and these are also explained in the
tutorials that you will have the access
to as a part of this program so from
visualization of genomic data to
exploration analysis and hand hypothesis
testing we have it all covered
after you register you will be
redirected to the courses tab here you
can search for any course title use the
tags to find series of resources around
the topic or choose one of the
collections down below here we will look
at the getting started collection
once you complete a course you will gain
500 points for running a pipeline
you will get 100 points and for updating
your profile you will get another 100
points finally participation and group
activities will give you 10 points and
after achieving the learning outcomes
you would have learned some of the major
best practices in the field of
bioinformatics
you will be exposed to r and python
which are the two most powerful
programming languages
bioinformaticians will need to
understand how to use t-test regression
and other tests analyzing and managing
data in order to communicate important
information is another best practice in
bioinformatics
pipeline development and utilization is
another common practice
ultimately completing the precision
medicine program will help you enter the
field of bioinformatics since you will
learn several best practices
now i would like to uh ask oh justine to
take over the stage and also
play for us the recording
by our ceo
mr eliot brodsky for today's session
oh just me stage is on yours
precision medicine
welcome to the allmix logic
bioinformatics for precision medicine
program
precision medicine is changing the way
we understand diagnose and treat major
life-threatening diseases this
transformation is driven in part by
computational technologies as well as
high-throughput molecular data that is
being collected from patients animal
models and large-scale cell line
experiments
in the program we will explore how the
various omics data types generated in
these studies can be analyzed and
integrated into the clinical process to
understand the basic biology associated
with communicable or infectious as well
as non-communicable or chronic diseases
including diagnostic strategies and
treatment selection development and
repurposing so in the first session
we'll review again the main topics of
the program introduce each one in
greater detail and provide you with a
guide how to use associated resources to
continue this journey after the session
you should have a good sense of
bioinformatic applications in precision
medicine completing the session video
and associated resources will give you a
great grasp on how data analysis skills
and new technologies like next
generation sequencing are used today in
this field you will also see various
examples that you can use to focus on
oncology
neurodegenerative and infectious
diseases in this session we will learn
about clinical and molecular data in the
context of risk profiling diagnosis and
therapeutic decisions
we will also go through various next
generation sequencing data types such as
genomics transcriptomics and
metagenomics
finally we will learn about the process
of how discovery in the lab
leads to real life applications or how
insights from bioinformatics analysis
can be translated to the clinic
to understand clinical decisions where
bioinformatics is used for precision
medicine we will look at various data
sources such as basic information about
patients or clinical data like age sex
ethnicity in their environment
data that describes disease history and
diagnosis treatments and comorbidities
and molecular profiling that allows us
to perform genotyping based on snips in
the dna
identify biomarkers or look at
microbiome composition
clinical data typically includes data
such as demographics
labs and medical history
the list of collected variables can vary
significantly based on each patient in
most cases this data can come from a
variety of sources like electronic
health records medication insurance
claims and family history
for the most part it is divided into
patient information as well as describes
their interactions or encounters with
the medical provider recently the
sources have increasingly digitized and
integrated
leading to an expanded number of
variables with various relevancy for
each case
some studies are starting to incorporate
many of the clinical sources of
information with molecular profiling
environmental factors as well as mobile
health and even social media while some
of the data types are more accurate than
others these all have been used to study
disease for example in the current
pandemic
all of these have been used to track
disease spread and identify potential
at-risk individuals or groups
pharmaceutical companies are referring
to this as real-world data or data that
can be used to evaluate responses to
treatment
and improve selection of patient
candidates for clinical trials
for many diseases molecular data is
increasingly important and relies on
complex bioinformatics analyses
like gene expression analyses commonly
found snips metabolism information and
an array of various biomarkers or
disease and treatment efficacy these
molecular patterns in association with
clinical data can help refine strategies
for diagnostics and therapy selection
new discoveries in molecular data lead
to a better understanding of complex
diseases at the subcellular level and
help identify novel drug targets or
opportunities for drug repurposing
for the clinician advanced molecular
profiling reveals the underlying
biological drivers of disease and can
help explain disease symptoms using
genomics proteomics transcriptomics
epigenomics and even metagenomics these
molecular markers affect how a patient
is diagnosed and lead to a number of
improvements
risk prediction or
risk stratification
prognosis of outcomes for treatment
modalities such as individual drugs or
combinations of drugs
selection of target therapeutics for
patients with complex diseases
and continuous monitoring of disease
changes over time
one of the great examples of how such
treatment has affected cancer is the
example of breast cancer
so we see that from 1971
to 2011
the rate of survival has increased from
about 50 percent to over 85 percent one
of the reasons was because studying
cancer herceptin was developed as a
targeted therapeutic
it's a monoclonal antibody that has been
used to treat her2 positive breast
cancer patients since the 1990s it works
by targeting the her2 receptor
preventing cancer growth some breast
cancers express too much her2 protein
triggering the cells to multiply very
rapidly today this trend with targeted
treatment has increased
other monoclonal antibodies such as
protrusimob or pergetta have been
developed
the targeted therapy has gotten even
more advanced
tdm1 cadicla an antibody drug
combination has been approved for use in
the treatment of her2 positive breast
cancers antibody drug combinations work
like a smart bomb delivering
chemotherapy directly to cancer cells by
attaching to their her2 positive
receptors targeted therapies have
transformed their approach to breast
cancers
and offer an opportunity to cure even
later stage breast cancers in certain
patients now a lot of this is done using
molecular profiling
one such test called oncotype dx
looks at the expression of 21 different
genes in a patient's primary tumor a
tumor's gene expression pattern shows
whether or not it will be responsive to
chemotherapy or whether endocrine
therapy alone such as tamoxifen could be
a better choice a recent study showed
that patients scoring on the low to mid
risk range could safely skip
chemotherapy completely
which would lead to avoiding the hair
loss neuropathy weight loss and other
side effects that often come
with chemotherapy
but this approach has further developed
and today molecular markers of disease
have led to a complete reclassification
of breast cancers into several different
molecular subtypes
these subtypes continue to evolve
leading to a better treatment of this
complex disease which is the fifth
leading cause of cancer-related deaths
annually with more than 265 000 people
diagnosed with it in the united states
alone every year other multi-atomic
studies help change the way that we can
understand other cancers such as liver
cancer or heptacellular carcinoma in the
2017 publication in cell reports the
cancer genome atlas research network
published their analysis of integrated
multi-omics data that led to a much
better understanding of liver cancer
risk such as infection with hepatitis b
and c as well as other factors like
alcohol consumption ethnicity and other
comorbidities
such comprehensive studies continue to
yield results even today more data is
being collected and analyzed by
bioinformaticians leading to an even
greater precision and making it possible
to improve the way treatment is
delivered or even find new treatments
that are less harmful and more effective
for certain patients the role of next
generation sequencing in medicine has
changed dramatically over the past
decade to understand why and how let's
look at several methods of molecular
profiling
explore the process of second generation
high throughput sequencing also known as
next generation sequencing or ngs and
see how such data can be analyzed to
discover specific clinically relevant
data points for a medical procedure the
growth in high throughput data is
largely driven by cheaper faster and
more efficient sequencing called next
generation sequencing or simply ngs from
about 100 million in 2001 which is the
cost of what it took to sequence the
full human genome to approximately 3
million by 2008 and by 2017
the cost of a sequence genome was close
to one thousand dollars just recently
ultima genomics announced its goal to
make the full genome sequence available
at a revolutionary cost of one hundred
dollars
this places whole genome sequencing at a
comparable cost to most tests like the
x-ray
recall that it's been over 70 years
since the structure and function of dna
was discovered 50 years have been spent
since that time sequencing the human
genomes in 2015 the 1000 genome project
brought a significant number of whole
genomes sequenced and available to the
research community
100 000 whole genomes were already
available by 2018
and today there's an ever increasing
number of data sets that are available
to help researchers and clinicians
understand
subcellular processes and the dna
omics data including such that is
provided by next generation sequencing
includes a variety of types
phenomics refers to high throughput
imaging or characterization of phenotype
genomics allows us to identify mutations
in the genome
so what is the observed sequence
compared to the reference
epigenomics allows us to study
epigenetic variation or variation that
is not dependent on the actual sequence
of the genome
this includes such methods as dna
methylation
transcriptomics allows us to understand
gene expression
or how much of a certain gene
is being expressed in a cell or a tissue
this is done using a variety of
platforms
platforms are instruments that produce
digital
omics data
so those can be divided into two types
short read sequencers and long read
sequencers
and they can be used to sequence either
targeted amplicon or whole genome or
untargeted dna in rna sequences in most
cases for clinical use
we will refer to either whole exome
or targeted panel sequencing because in
most cases whole genome sequences
sequencing just carries too much
information to be clinically relevant
the number of annotated snips is much
lower
than the total number of positions in
the human genome which is over 3 billion
long genomic variation is typically
calculated by the proportion of known
snips present in a particular gene
and this can range from genotyping where
we group patients
by
their genotype or
some special features in their genome
and in some cases we are going to be
looking for pathogenic snips
snips
are single nucleotide polymorphisms
or a single nucleotide position that has
been identified as relatively prevalent
in the population or over one percent of
individuals for example bracha one and
bracket ii testing is extensively used
to identify women that are at risk of
developing breast or ovarian cancer in
fact 44 of women who inherit a harmful
bracha 1 genetic mutation will develop
ovarian cancer by the age of 80. to
summarize omnics data can be used to
understand what is happening
within the tissue or a single cell and
typically
those can include a variety of dna
changes
gene expression changes epigenetic
changes
as well as microbiome changes in the
individual
when combined with clinical or
phenotypic data some of that information
can be clinically relevant
that means that it will be used at
different stages of identifying risk
developing a precise diagnosis
or even selecting treatment that is most
appropriate and effective for the
individual and that is why next
generation sequencing data
is central to precision medicine most
bioinformatic enough
all right so let's just pause for a
moment and
let's see if the participants have any
queries related to the topics covered so
far or regarding the session or about
the program if so please put them in the
chat box below and we have them be happy
to answer your queries
so we are waiting so if you have any
queries please put them in the chat box
and we will be happy to answer
all right so uh in the upcoming uh
topics we will be uh discussing about uh
uh the process of how discovery in the
lab leads to real life applications and
how insights from bioinformatics are
used in the clinic all right so we have
a query from uh mukesh is this um
helpful in machine learning data science
so one of our mentor will be able to
answer that
yeah hello mukesh yes this will be
helpful in setting up machine learning
analysis so for machine learning
analysis you will need a structured data
so uh performing a genomics data
analysis or
analysis from the
past you files or based on the sequence
data is one of the way that you can
achieve or where you can convert the
unstructured digital data into
structured digital data once the data is
structured or in another way once the
data is in the format of a table
arranged as rows and columns then you
can use
that data to variety of different
machine learning
models or different advanced statistical
methods so this will definitely help in
data science methods using machine
learning
machine learning tools
thank you or dr raghav or does the
participants have any further queries
uh
okay we have one question will the
session recordings be uploaded my work
timing coincides with class schedule
so yes the session recordings will be
uploaded and would be made available to
the
participants of the program
and the time for the sessions would be
the same that is
10 am cst and
8 30
pm isd
i hope that answers your question thank
you
all right for the next question yes it
is already uh replacing
your sequencing next generation
sequencing high throughput sequencing
methods are
the most prevalent and
they are most sought after for
genomics and transcriptomic studies as
it's been
explained in these videos so sanger
sequencing right now are the
technology of the past they are not high
throughput sequencing they are low
throughput
and we have another question what is the
role of artificial intelligence in next
generation sequencing
i mean
artificial intelligence doesn't have a
specific role in the sequencing process
itself but as i mentioned
once the sequencing has been done you
are going to create a lots and lots of
digital data
wherever you have the availability of a
large number of large volume of data you
can expect artificial intelligence to
play a significant role in those areas
like
like financial
finance by finance for example like
internet of things and like uh yeah
astronomy right astrophysics so all of
these
fields are creating
huge volumes of data and you can see
artificial intelligence are playing
significant role in those
areas likewise in bioinformatics also we
will actually see
a significant role from artificial
intelligence to make sense or make
relations
or understand trends in the
huge volume of data that we are going to
generate or we are generating ourselves
what's the difference between second
generation sequencing and third
generation sequencing
i think muhammad you can take this from
these theories from the from google also
it depends on the type of sequencing
being performed so all sequencing
[Music]
makes the aim of the sequencing is is
very simple
to convert what is a biological sample
into a digital data and there are
different ways of achieving it and each
with uh with each and every development
that has been um
or that is that has been uh in the
process for the sequencing methods there
are slight increase in the signal to
noise ratio for different ones so if you
want specific answers between second
generation sequencing and third
generation sequencing for for example
for bioinformatics examination
you can consult wikipedia or google or
even illumina website is a
huge is a very good source for
for these types of
queries
yes and we have some more questions any
relationship between single cell
analysis
and metabolomics
uh transcriptomics and genomics
uh daniel yes single cell analysis is
mostly preferred for
for rna-seq data right in order to
understand or in order to
characterize the heterogeneity that one
will actually expect or one will
actually
find out in any sample so bulk rna-seq
or bulk transcriptomics analysis is
is a way of characterizing samples
by averaging out the expression patterns
present in those samples and single cell
rna sheet or singleton transcriptomics
methods or
processes are a way of trying to
individualize those cells
based on their expression pattern so we
will obviously find
different applications for bulk rna seq
or bulk transcriptomics analysis and
single cell aren't present
and
there is another question by sushmita
there is always a conflict about data
analysis of omics data as we have lots
of data generated
where the study objects
uh sample individuals are less how to
deal with the problem should we add more
replicates technically
if you can approach
sorry if you can approach the
problem of um of lower number of
observations or lower number of samples
from the data generation point of view
that is the best way to
tackle this challenge this is a
challenge and in some cases this is a
tremendous problem
and there are different
methodologies in the
that you can adapt
your machine learning models or your
machine learning codes or your different
advanced statistical analysis so that
the impact of the lower number of
samples
remains very low and it does not affect
your end result or your interpretation
so there are ways to
get around these
problems and issues
what is the prospectus and scope of
genomic data analysis in terms of
patient care and diagnosis we are
actually seeing the change right now
isn't that dr davinash so for most of
the cancer genomics or for most of the
cancer patients one of the sought out
methods to characterize the cancer is is
to send the sample for transcriptomics
or whole exome or whole genome analysis
right so we not only are reliant on
histological characterization of the
samples for example we are also reliant
or we also want to perform genomic data
characterization or or mix data
characterization of the samples so that
we can get a more um
let's say
more
a perspective that is
that is going to add
to one more dimension of whatever has
been
available from physiological
laboratories right
genomics data or omix data analysis
gives you the molecular perspective of
the samples
and
what the laboratories are producing it
gives you
a different perspective of the sample so
together they can actually increase or
they can actually improve the uh
diagnostics accuracy and prognostics
accuracy there it is already seen right
right in developed countries it's part
of the regimen and in
developing countries like india and
other countries it is picking up
thank you so much dr raghav so if the
participants have any other queries
please put them in the chat box
and i would like to request or just to
continue playing the session
analyses
are going to be considered as
pre-clinical
that means it is based on data generated
in lab experiments or retrospective
studies
to explore these let's look at examples
of cell lines derived from patient
tumors in oncology
animal models of human disease
and explore how these can be used
alongside databases on various specific
diseases for example tcga in oncology
then we will discuss how such insights
can be validated and what considerations
they bring to biobanking and clinical
trials next
and experiments are already affecting
research hospitals and are used by
pharmaceutical industry to design
specific treatments and adapt them to
the needs of individual patients
a lot of times
not all of these experiments are
possible on real patients instead
we can select tumors in different types
of patients
produce those tumors as immortalized
cell lines and use those cell lines to
understand the basic biology
unfortunately that biology cannot be
fully studied just using cell lines
because cell lines don't have all of the
elements of the system or the whole body
that actually functions as a whole
and so in many cases in oncology instead
of just using cell lines there are also
tumors that could be extracted in full
from a patient
grafted into an animal model
and then studied in terms of their
interaction with the rest of the body
ultimately such experiments
can provide better insights into
biological factors that are relevant for
patients
and different types of tests could be
first performed on these models
before we actually develop a clinical
trial where such treatments or
diagnostic procedures are used on actual
patients this is also changing the way
that we apply big data analysis
techniques or bioinformatics in real
world clinical needs so typical process
is to collect integrate and analyze big
data coming from a variety of sources
and ultimately change the way that this
can be used in a big data approach for
precision medicine we can see this
oftentimes used when large large-scale
data is being collected on a particular
disease a good example is the cancer
genome atlas the cancer genome atlas is
a work performed over several decades to
collect samples with multi-omic data on
patients and use their clinical
phenotypes to find important
associations the cancer genome data is
available through the genome data
commons portal that allows us to find
multi-omics data sets with clinical
information
about each sample which gives a much
better understanding of how cancer
variation is
diagnosed and treated and how successful
those treatments can be these
large-scale data sets are continuing to
be collected and today we have the all
of us data set as well the all of us
research program which is led by the
national institutes of health is
building one of the largest biomedical
data resources of its kind the all of us
research hub stores health data from a
diverse group of participants from
across the united states researchers can
access all of us data and tools to
conduct studies to help improve our
understanding of human health
now it also provides us with a much
better understanding of what we call
healthy or the variation of healthy
individuals that can be used as a
reference when we study subgroups of
patients or patients that are of
different ages
sexes ethnic backgrounds
and socio-economic status in addition
there are projects that are aimed at
characterizing the healthy condition
and pre-clinical variation one such
example is the nih human microbiome
project that allows us to look at
different types of microbiome
perturbation that is associated with
different types of diseases
these include depression autism spectrum
disorder cardiovascular disease asthma
arthritis cancer and diabetes
by understanding the microbiome
diversity composition and changes
associated with different types of
phenotypes we can start seeing the
impact of the microbiome on diagnostics
but also treatment because patients with
different microbiome can metabolize
treatment at different rates
now that we have reviewed the rationale
for bioinformatics and ngs in biomedical
research in the clinic let's review case
studies of clinical research with real
data these include oncology
neurodegenerative diseases like
alzheimer's disease and infectious
diseases like covet 19 malaria or ebola
we can look at how viral genomics and
evolution can help us understand the
spread of a disease and identify
variants of concern in pathogens
or
genetic predisposition of some
populations to be more susceptible to
acquire disease and potentially
have worse outcomes we can look at
immune responses where we characterize
gene expression and study biomarkers or
genes that are associated with a
particular response and sometimes we can
look at
microbiome
and see how microbiome plays a role in
disease progression drug metabolism and
also predisposes certain people to
different clinical risks on the onyx
logic portal you will find a number of
case studies in curated data sets around
these different topics some of them are
based on full analysis of data sets that
are already published
simply by following the steps described
in these case studies you will be able
to make important discoveries that today
are being used in the clinic some of
them have to do with drug metabolism
identification of somatic mutations in
tumor development
inherited or germline mutations like the
sickle cell anemia rare genetic diseases
as well as drug resistance associated
with different types of antibiotics and
pathogens oftentimes just by reading the
abstract you get a good grasp of how
bioinformaticians can use such data to
model precision medicine for example on
this project modeling precision medicine
of breast cancer you will find how
researchers use machine learning to
study transcriptomic data and identify
subgroups of individuals
that are going to respond differently to
different treatments in the study
researchers use multi-omics data
integration to look at different types
of molecular profiles
integrate them and compare them to
reference databases like the tcga to
understand response to treatment to
drugs that are either already used in
the clinic or being studied in clinical
trials to continue learning we invite
you to explore these associated
resources for the lecture
we will go over the coursework the case
studies and other examples from
literature
to benefit from today's lecture you can
select one of these to refresh your
memory of basic terminology
learn more about the various techniques
or practice what we have learned with
curated data sets on the topics that we
covered in today's session
the contents of the session correspond
with practical lessons that you can
complete independently that are
available on the onyx logic learn portal
with the full course specific lessons
that are of relevance to today's session
include
lesson two bioinformatics in healthcare
from course one introduction to
bioinformatics
in this lesson you will get an overview
of examples from healthcare area where
bioinformatics can be applied you will
also see examples and videos of medical
professionals discussing bioinformatics
in precision medicine applications
another good course to look at is bytes
and molecules
this course is a great place for those
who was confused by a lot of the terms
that we used in today's lecture anyone
that would like to review the basic
terminology and get a good overview of
topics that we cover in this course
should look at this course in full
but specifically we looked at this
lesson
lesson six called introduction to
genomics if you are interested in
genomics you can also look at these
additional lessons in the course 3
course called genomics in lesson 2 you
will see how you can work with dna
sequences in r
and in lesson 3 you will get an
introduction to large-scale genomics the
full course contains a lot more
information that you can choose to
explore independently some of these will
be covered in the future lectures but do
not worry about completing them for now
at the end you will also find examples
that i already mentioned these examples
include such projects like ebola
immune response changes in cancer
modeling cancer precision medicine
or tuberculosis infection and treatment
finding drug resistance variants
so let's recap what we have learned so
far
first
we learned how combining clinical and
molecular data helps reveal underlying
factors contributing to the disease
which further helps us provide a precise
diagnosis and effective treatment to the
patient
further we learned about next-generation
sequencing technologies for genomic
transcriptomic and metagenomic data that
provide important insights for precision
medicine applications
we also discussed the role of
bioinformatics in taking research
results from the lab to the clinic to
benefit patient treatment and diagnosis
finally we introduced a set of case
studies in precision medicine from
inherited sickle cell anemia to drug
resistance and mycobacterium
tuberculosis
in the next session session two on
genomic data analysis we will go one
step further to better understand what
is genomic data
how do you perform variant calling
analysis
what is the difference between germline
and somatic mutations
and how to determine a variance clinical
relevance at the end of session 2 you
will have a thorough understanding of
genomic data
variant calling analysis as well as
specific techniques for clinical
annotation of variants in cancer
[Music]
thank you
for playing the session and we have few
more queries in the chat box
so
first we have uh divya is asking uh
would this include the r program for the
analysis
the fear
that
the associated resources also
includes a specific lesson that does
this analysis or part of the analysis
with r as a tool
but most of the heavy
analysis like a pipeline
running the pipeline is actually taken
care by running it in the back end which
is the
tbio info server big data bioinformatics
server you need a high performance
computing to
work with the fastq files and then
produce structured data and then from
these variants that are being called
which has to be this very important
pipeline has to be running the t bioinfo
server
and
from these variants
we can perform analysis with r to
annotate them or to compare them
contrast so those are actually included
in the associative resources and yeah
some of them will be covered in the
future lectures
so we also have uh
occupational opportunities and with
certificates for these courses and
yeah cancer analysis actually
talk about what are the certificates
that will be provided after completing
these courses
yes i'll take that question up i would
be just talking about
uh the registration partner
and also how
you can go through these resources
uh
so if you have no technical question
left
i would now like to take this session
ahead
all right so i'm here on the omniproject
learn portal oh just we had shared the
link earlier in the chat box i'll share
it once again
if you have signed up great if you have
not yet signed up please
take the minutes and do sign up
uh having a having an account on the
portal is absolutely free of cost and
you can proceed further by registering
for the program to get the access to the
resources that we were discussing about
today
so uh all you need to do is just click
on the login button and
it will allow you to create an account
for yourself with several options
uh yes sir i'm just coming uh to that
point where i'll be also discussing
about the scholarship opportunities that
you can obey
right okay so uh
meanwhile it's loading and i would like
to take you all to the program page
so here is the program page and i wanted
to discuss with you all the syllabus of
the precision medicine
program that we'll be going through in
the next sessions and also how to
register yourself if you have not done
so uh till now this was the first
session where we thought of inviting all
the interested participants of the
program so that you know how
the sessions would be conducted and
because it was an introductory session
today we did not want to overwhelm you
so we kept it a short and light and this
is the program page i have shared the
link in the chat box with all of you
when you scroll down you can find the
sessions shared view
so we have listed
on which all dates okay i think there's
a system error over here it should be
july 14 okay so we have listed here all
the topics that we would be covering for
each and every session uh on like all
the topics here we have listed so today
we discussed about introduction to
biomedics or precision medicine
next we are going to talk about the
advancements in precision medicine and
then we'll talk about genomic data
analysis next we will discuss oncology
data resources uh that would include raw
data and public databases
after that we are going to talk about
the transcriptomic data analysis aspect
for precision medicine and then we'll
talk about health wellness and ethical
concerns
next we'll discuss in the next session
we'll discuss about phylogenetic
analysis and multiple sequence alignment
and then talk about host response to
infections
we'll also discuss about precision
medicine for neuroscience and finally
metagenomic data analysis so we have
covered a whole range of topics here for
various omix data analysis in the field
of precision medicine and here we have
listed the topics that that would be
covered in each and every session
now a point to be noted here is that all
the program participants will be able to
access the
session recordings here on the program
page itself
we'll upload the session recording here
on the program page once the session is
over
and you can see the recording here under
each and every session also each and
every session of the program will be
supplemented with some coursework
associated online resources that you
will be supposed to go through and
complete
once you go through the recording and
also complete the associated resources
next you are supposed to click on on the
complete session button and you have to
do the same for each and every session
this way you will be able to get a
certificate
so i'll just very briefly take you to
the profile and certification tab as
well and answer the questions related to
certification and how do we get it all
the resources that are covered etc
before i do that i would just very
shortly like to discuss the registration
steps so we have uh three different
subscription types that the
interested user can pick from
one is for 45 days another one is for 16
days and the third one is for 90 days
now uh obviously as the days are
mentioned you will get the access to the
program the resources that includes the
amiclogic loan portal all the courses
out there and also the divide for server
transfer analysis uh
platform
you'll get the access to all of these
resources for 45 days if you uh pick the
first option
and also we have tried to mention the
other resources that you will get the
access to
and if you pick uh the access for 60
days then you will also get to work on
your research proposal for the work on a
research project um after you after you
are done with your training for the
program
and the license type that you will get
on the dbi info server would be that of
an educational license and you'll be
allowed to
uh also meet the experts in one
one-on-one sessions and next we have the
90 days of the subscription level
where you will also work on a research
project alongside your training part so
once the training is complete you will
work on your research project
and to work on your research project you
will have a research license on the d
bio info server where you will be able
to uh
extract data from various big data
repositories and then upload that data
after preparing it on the t bind for
server and do your own analysis get your
results and that way you would be able
to work on your own independent research
project under mental guidance
so that is the difference between three
these three different types of
subscription levels that are possible
for you to uh become a part of the
program
with and
i would now like to share the link to
the scholarship form
so those who are interested to avail a
scholarship on this program please fill
out this form
i will also put the link in the chat box
please fill out the form on the
scholarship page here
our team will review your
application
and then get back to you on this once
you have filled the form please let us
know you can also email us at marketing
at the rate fine dot
by your marketing as logic.com
for
any further questions
uh
milaj
i'm not sure if that was the case the
sales team would be able to help you
with that
maybe you might have
used a scholarship coupon code that's
why the amount for you might be less
all right
so that was it now going back to the
page where if anyone has any questions
regarding
registration that we just discussed or
scholarship from please put it in the
chat so that we can discuss that now
es gene the prizes for all the summer
training programs are the same
cg code girl could you please first of
all tell us your full name in the chat
box and also uh this was the session for
the registered participants as well and
we'll be having the next session only
for the registered parties events on
june 16 that is day after tomorrow
all right
they have answered your question for the
possibility of getting scholarships you
can fill out the form
and also send the link to you once again
so that you have it handy
eligible for the scholarships dr fatima
it's not specific to in indian citizens
it's for everyone around the world
i'm saying i'm sending the link once
again in the chat box you can fill the
form
uh mukesh uh it seems here and trust
here to enroll for data science or
paramedical data program
we'll send you the details over an email
please share your email id with us in
the chat itself
so for muhammad i'll just
open our teapot info server to show you
the platform uh in the initial slides
that i went through i did discuss about
the team info server where you can deal
with the your own data or data from big
data repositories and on various
analysis pipelines for these different
domains of transcriptomics genomics
metagenomics epigenomics or data science
as well be it machine learning and
supervise supervised analysis even
single cell transcriptomics so there's a
huge possibility of data analysis on the
d binary
platform
once you uh register for the program you
will be going through a lot of resources
and also practice uh hands-on pipelines
on the server and
then get
an understanding and clear good
understanding of how these pipelines
work how to get the data how do you
download your output files and then
finally interpret biological insights
okay so spanish has shared the details
uh in the chat itself thank you spash
and uh you can reach out to us at
marketing advert or maxlogic.com and
also contact us on our indian number uh
which is active on whatsapp as well
all right so that was it for today's